this is the new audi a4 it won't hit the
showroom floors till the end of the year
but drive it has the exclusive
opportunity to examine it in detail
some of the elaborate innovations aren't
immediately apparent take the drag
coefficient of just 0.26 in the Avant to
achieve that low value nips and tucks
were made to the entire car for example
the air intakes at the front
inden follow me howdy project manager
victor olivares marita since the
extra-wide s-line bumper would normally
be an aerodynamic disadvantage but the
new audi a4 has this air curtain that
deflects the wind into this hole and the
outflows go to the wheels in this is the
silo with this via for the art form gets
in there India raiden the side mirrors
also affect wind resistance these three
bumps are small but they have a big
effect is a clarity the man from Audi
says these three ribs break up any
turbulence that develops that's not only
an aerodynamic advantage but also an
acoustic one and so it makes sense to
order acoustic glass for the windows
that will make the interior as quiet as
in an e 8 like most new cars the new a4
weighs less than its predecessor up to
120 kilograms less 15 have been cut from
the body new technology has made the
engine lighter and more fuel-efficient
the lighter weight has lowered co2
emissions to between 100 and 120 9 grams
per kilometer but if you want a hybrid
or electric version tough luck the new
a4 comes in 3 gasoline powered versions
and for diesels putting out up to 200
kilowatts another engine envisioned for
it burns natural gas but it won't be on
the market for another year
the innovations in the interior are more
noticeable
it's rocky organism our car tester Matas
kirat is fascinated by all the Audi a4s
technical gadget ray the press of a
button toggles the completely digital
instrument cluster between ground
instruments showing just the essentials
and smaller round instruments with a lot
more room for additional information
there are touch sensors on the switches
for the air conditioning as soon as you
touch the switch your shown all the
options and mutters particularly likes
the fact that the ambient interior
lighting can be adjusted in a wide range
of steps from purple through blue green
yellow and red to a completely neutral
white finish my advice instead car
behind the rear hatch is 505 liters of
baggage space 15 liters more than in the
predecessor along with the station wagon
the a4 also comes as a sedan except for
the rear they're the same and a casual
observer might mistake them for their
predecessor so what is really knew about
the a for Alice the Audi spokesman says
everything is new a new platform new
hood new headlights everything's new
except maybe a few bolts on the wheels
went off the roads of America finish the
a4 will first meet the public in
September at the iaa international motor
show in frankfurt then we'll see whether
it attracts buyers even without
alternative engines
as montes really likes how the new a4
looks and he can't wait to take it for a
test drive